and I thought you were gonna die before
but I think that it's I will die yes so
you're gonna win that one but I think
it's because
um
I think it's because you go so hard like
you just have I mean it's just whatever
you've always had I'm like a lot of it I
think is also Envy I'm like how does he
keep going he watching his social media
feed is making I'm tired like I'll go
I'll see three three reels a Year's on
Instagram and have to go get a massage
you know I'm saying I'm tired it's like
wow how does he keep going I don't know
I think it's the thing I I think uh I
don't know
I think I'm a little bit of a holic it's
like I'm I'm a holic of a lot of things
but not full-blown like I'm a workaholic
I'm a workaholic I'm a workaholic
hardcore and I think maybe that's where
I put my aholism in is in like a healthy
place but it's not healthy it it pulls
from your family and your your your
sense of well-being and yours and but
like I don't mind being a workaholic
because I feel like you only get one
especially now because you only get one
opportunity to shine so you get an
opportunity to sell some tickets
in my opinion you you better be on the
road trying to sell some tickets if you
if you pop you know like if you have a
moment and you pop
and people go I want to see that I want
to see what that guy's like live you
know they will forget about you so you
kind of got to go out and be like I'm
here
um I trust me I took two and I took two
and two months off and I was off social
media pretty much like I was [ __ ]
around with it every now and then but
there'll be days where I'd have like two
stories up and I'd forget and I'd skip a
whole day and and I and I had to remind
myself you have to go back to work like
you need to get ready to go back to work
and I I could very easily be like
everyone else and go like
yeah man I think I'm just gonna do
podcasts you know and and I'm not and
not push it as hard as I do
but I only got one opportunity I'm not
gonna live forever and and I definitely
want to make sure that my family's
comfortable and I and I I love stand up
and I love podcasting I love my cooking
show something's burning I love I love
two bears I love being I love all of it
I love [ __ ] around with Joe on me on
social media and taunting them and and
hearing the text I get back from I got
five texts from Joe in my pocket and I
get episode like sober October's getting
ready and so we're [ __ ] around and
challenging each other I love that [ __ ]
I love that but I love all of it I love
you know I love
taking in content as well it's like well
you love getting up every day I mean you
really love being a lie you love it I
love being live like today is a great
day
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one